Rob here with a gamespot news update  Rainbow six siege has been delayed  originally expected in October of this  year Ubisoft announced today in a blog  post that the game is now being delayed  until December first 2015 for all  regions Ubisoft said player feedback has  been essential to the development of  Rainbow six siege based on the feedback  we've received and based on our own  internal tests we felt that there are  adjustments and improvements we can make  including improving the co-op experience  across all game modes weapon and gadget  balancing as well as menu and interface  navigation we're taking a little more  time to make these changes and we think  it's the right call the upcoming beta  for Rainbow six siege available by  pre-ordering the game will commence as  scheduled on September 24 for more on  Ubisoft delays at gamespot.com because I  bet the division will get delayed again